a new vaccine requirement going into
effect for all nevada high school
seniors this week victoria saha joining
us now live in studio with why doctors
think this vaccine is so very important
yes brian starting on july 1st this new
rule will go into effect all seniors
must have the meningitis vaccine by the
time school starts for many parents you
may remember your child getting a first
dose when they're around 11 years old
now they must get a second dose
we are not joking as pediatricians you
know that these are very serious
infections dr kerry weijie sinha says
she has already seen an influx of
patients coming to her office to get the
meningitis vaccine we're in well check
season so we are today and the last
couple weeks we've been seeing a lot of
my seniors coming in for this required
vaccine as well as the ones that are in
middle school she says meningitis can
start as a contagious bacterial
infection which can affect the brain and
when not treated you can pass away
within 24 hours i have seen a little
baby pass of
another form of meningitis strep
pneumonia meningitis and
it the child passed it was horrific i
never want to see that again mom jessica
mujica has a senior in high school she
says she won't be taking any chances i
know it's deadly you know so i will
definitely have my daughter take the
vaccine i just want i just i always
check everything out first she herself
almost had a meningitis scare 10 years
ago i was completely quarantined
no visitors
full pp
oh gear
same as what you see them wearing for
covid this new requirement applies to
all high school seniors throughout the
state of nevada whether you are in a
public private or charter school
the southern nevada health district has
set up a few different locations to get
your back to school vaccines we'll have
that information up on our website at
8newsnow.com
brian